When parents or kids are looking for some
good clean fun, nothing's a safer bet than
a Disney movie.
Made for kids, parents, or the whole family,
everyone knows that some jokes or references
are aimed squarely at parents.
But take a closer look, and you'll be shocked
at how many dirty jokes snuck by you the first
time.
Here are Screen Rant's 10 Hidden Adult Jokes
in Popular Disney Films.
Ratatouille
Having a rat running around in your pants
leads to plenty of adult humor on its own,
but when the stars of Ratatouille take a secret
meeting inside a produce cooler, they have
to scramble for an excuse.
The chef's reply is too subtle for kids to
catch, but think about it for even a second,
and it's clear this joke is implying something
that no kids movie could even come close to
commenting on.
Hercules
The son of Zeus' and his journey from zero
to hero is based on the Greek myth, but it's
not the only classical story alluded to.
There's no question Hercules has some family
drama to deal with, but one character makes
his problems seem like child's play.
Since the play he's referring to stars a king
who marries his own mother, and has four children
with her, it's a joke we're glad kids won't
understand.
Aladdin
The friendship between Aladdin and his Genie
is one for the ages, and it's a safe bet that
more than half of Robin Williams' jokes or
references go over kids' heads.
When you combine that comedy with the male
leads, you wind up with Genie letting Aladdin
know just how much he means to him - but making
it clear that he only likes him... as a friend.
We never would have even though about it,
until now.
Cars
Pixar's tale of a world of cars has more dirty
jokes buried within it than will probably
ever be found, but not all of them are hidden
- or polite.
When Lightning McQueen comes across one of
his racing heroes, he lets Mater know just
how many Piston Cups he won in his career.
Mater can't help but make a joke that isn't
exactly clever - but it's definitely not suitable
for kids.
The Lion King
Fans have been looking for hidden references
in The Lion King for years, from words written
floating in the air, to secret messages.
But one of the most adult moments is so obvious,
only an innocent child could miss it.
When Simba is reunited with his childhood
friend, Nala, romance isn't far behind.
They start by wrestling like they did as kids,
until Nala gives the hero a look that makes
her real intentions painfully obvious to every
adult in the room.
Honestly, it's hard to believe the animators
were never told to at least tone it down.
Tangled
It's true that when people go looking for
sinister or adult images or messages in Disney
movies, they're willing to call almost anything
cold, hard proof.
But sometimes, it's hard to dismiss their
evidence.
Take, for example, a promotional poster used
for Disney's Tangled, where Rapunzel is using
her hair to entangle Flynn Rider, her future
husband.
You might think her hair spelling "S-E-X"
is a stretch, but considering the hair could
have made virtually any shape, it's definitely
suspicious, at the very least, especially
since it happened with The Lion King before...
Beauty and the Beast
Every Disney fan knows that "No One Drinks
Like Gaston," with the burly brawler's drinking
just one sign of his manliness.
The other?
That he's never even heard of shaving his
chest... or anything else.
It might sound like a harmless line meant
for fun, not a sexual reference... but when
you notice the obvious wink Gaston throws
as he says the word "inch," you'll never hear
the line the same way again.
Wreck-it Ralph
This video game story may not be cute or cuddly,
but it's definitely not trying to offend any
younger or older viewers with edgy humor.
Or is it?
When ralph returns home to find he's the only
person not invited to a party in his own game,
he has some choice words for Pac-Man, who's
apparently on the guest list.
The words may describe Pac-Man's gameplay,
but the risky use of the word “cherry”
apparently got the blessing from everyone
behind the scenes.
Toy Story 3
An adult joke doesn't need to be complicated
to be funny, and it doesn't have to be raunchy
to warrant a second look.
When Ken and Barbie first meet in the third
Toy Story adventure, they can't help but notice
they're made for each other.
While Ken gives Barbie a dose of charm, she
goes for a more... direct approach.
It's not as wild as some of our other entries,
but it's too blunt to think that even kids
would miss it completely.
Frozen
Disney's story of two sisters called out other
classic love stories, with Else thinking it
crazy that Anna would marry a man she just
met.
The skepticism is shared by Kristof, who tries
to prove she hardly knows her soon to be husband
- including his foot size.
It's a safe bet the women in the audience
gave the line a giggle, since it's an obvious
play on the idea that "size doesn't matter"
when it comes to a man's.....equipment.
Those are the best adult jokes we found hidden
in Disney movies, but are there any we missed?
Be sure to share your own favorite gags in
the comments, and subscribe to the channel
for more videos like this one.